[Música]
ansiedade e irritabilidade pensamentos
pessimistas baixa autoestima
esses são alguns dos sintomas da
depressão e é sobre isso que eu vou
falar hoje eu estou nesse tema porque
muitas pessoas não sabem o que é
depressão ou seja têm preconceito com
quem tem e também aconteceram algumas
vezes na minha família de pessoas terem
a doença e eu achei bem importante as
pessoas saberem um pouco mais sobre o
assunto
ao contrário do que muitos pensam e
sines é um absurdo depressão não é
frescura ou mimi é a segunda versão
precisam ser ouvidas e acolhidas
existe uma diferença muito grande entre
tristeza e depressão tristeza e alguma
coisa natural que acontece às vezes pelo
falecimento de alguém ou então por uma
separação que a depressão é alguma coisa
que é às vezes não tem um motivo
aparente
mas a pessoa fica com um tipo
ela não sabe ou não sabe se a vida tem
mais sentido e essas coisas
hoje em dia no mundo 300 milhões de
pessoas têm depressão o que é muita
gente as pessoas com depressão não
gostam de dizer que elas têm e é que nem
diz aqui você está bem eu estou ótima
mas na verdade ela está se sentindo
sozinha isolada substituído eu as
pessoas com depressão podem ser tratadas
por terapias anti depressivos elas devem
ser acolhidas
elas podem praticar atividades físicas
ou até escrever poemas
segundo a organização mundial de saúde
oms a depressão pode ser considerado o
segundo maior risco à saúde humana
ficando a só após doenças cardíacas
vocês como podem ajudar lembrando que a
depressão se não for tratada pode levar
ao suicídio
então obrigado pela atenção
[Música]